tomorrow marks the one-year anniversary
of the rust movie tragedy that killed
cinematographer Helena Hutchins welcome
everyone to Entertainment Tonight you
know there have been so many twists and
turns in this case including a new
development on how the movie will go on
but we start with this ET exclusive
we had such a great time making that
movie it was just interrupted in a Flash
and I think all of our lives have
changed forever rust actor swen Temple
we're not winning who recently starred
in Bandit with Josh Duhamel was on set
outside the movie Chapel when Alec
Baldwin accidentally shot
cinematographer Helena Hutchins with a
prop gun it's one of those things that
you just can't shake almost one year
later a new twist I was surprised that
you know they they came together and
that they said that they wanted to
finish the movie rust is set to resume
production next year but not back on the
original New Mexico set an attorney for
the film company tells E.T the
production is considering other
locations including in California but no
decisions have been made I'll be there
when they need me to be there
and um we'll hopefully make a beautiful
movie as part of a civil settlement the
late cinematographer's husband Matthew
Hutchins will executive produce for him
to come on board I mean is the only
reason why this movie is going to get
finished and he'll make sure that it's
done right are you doing okay no I'm not
Ashley I wish that she could have
finished this movie because I really
think it would have been something huge
for her she would have blown up this
would have been her Masterpiece as for
Alec he was last spotted out Sunday in
New York with three of his and hilarious
seven children do you feel guilt no no
the actor has denied any responsibility
in the shooting but could however face
criminal charges I don't know if this is
suspected blood or real blood but this
is fake when Alec and swen returned to
set the 31 year old says he just wants
to make halina proud I hope that she's
looking down from up above and she's
proud of what we're doing and that she
knows that
we're moving forward for her
and their husband is there for us
and I just hope that her memory lives on
forever
[Music]